já o mba e dói é que o carnaval é é um
foi lan roda e também também não está em
dólar não nem que o que eu fiz ontem a
pai de tony nada tome todas nem todas as
autonomias e tomara que eu me tirar o
esmalte do dente se não tomar o tristan
não fosse mãe contei quem é que tu comeu
a paz eu nem lembro de pouca coisa mas
estou lembrando mesmo foi uma loirinha a
cae também achando que papai que sei que
tem hora dele se une na página do enem
esse cabelo de um tal rapaz fosse o amor
de deus que essa história não foi eu
eu não lembro que eu nunca deixando só
fai um só vai vincular o quarto da série
men bolso de igor doido foi eleito pegou
não relaxou o que vou tomar gol de jael
só podia
ae